hello everyone and welcome to Round
seven of grand chest towards your next
move tournament in Levin and here we
have a game between Hikaru Nakamura and
Wesley so it's quite a weird game I'm
sure you'll agree but before we get to
the game I have to congratulate everyone
on your vast knowledge during the
previous photo photo challenge yes of
course it was the young Boris Gelfand
but surprisingly a lot of you actually
thought it was Tigran Petrosian I have
no idea why that is but as I'm sure you
enjoyed a different photo challenge
that's a bit more difficult than the
ones I gave you from the start so for
this one also a very nice photo
challenge that could be a bit difficult
but I will give you a hint so for this
photo challenge there will be two photos
of the same person so here is one hope
you know who it is and if this doesn't
drink well here is a second one so I
want to tell you who this is but I will
definitely tell you it's it's it's
definitely not a Joffrey from Game of
Thrones so I hope that you know helps
you out at least a little bit best of
luck to everyone now let's check out
this game as if you've seen my previous
videos from round or get or day 1 and
day 2 this is day three of the your next
move tournament here are the standings
after the second day so Wesley so is in
the lead and as you can see he called
Nakamura somewhere in the middle of the
table definitely I win in this run would
go a long way for him and we do have a
nice photo it's not really for oh it's
it's a you know I capture from the live
feed but one thing that's really I don't
know I don't know if this is like bad
marketing or something you all know Red
Bull is paying Nakamura you know he's on
a Red Bulls payroll to advertise them
but he never actually drinks the Red
Bull so he only has the Red Bull next to
him but it's it's never even opened so I
don't know if he already had too much or
he doesn't like the taste but he could
at least open it when it stands next to
him during a game you know that that
that would be good marketing I
I'd say but let's see this game so a
Nakamura has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 just seconds sorry about
that
uh-huh
Knight to f6 Bishop to F for preparing
the London system we have d5 III and c5
now D captures on c5 we have E six now
the bishop is ready to capture the c5
pawn and here you will if you check out
any beginners book about guarding upon
like this at every every book will tell
you you know just forget about this pawn
continue developing go Bishop d3 knight
of three castle and continue playing
this game but of course Hikaru is a
super grandmaster and super grandmasters
can play whatever they whatever they
like so he plays b4 he wants to protect
his extra pawn so okay we have a five
immediately challenging this de-spawn
chain c3 defending we have Bishop to d7
not allowing Bishop to b5 check Queen to
b3 and now a capture some B for C
capture some before and now the
immediate b6 so you can see how much
trouble white is already getting himself
into by defending this c5 pawn black is
immediately challenging it once again
and if you try something like pawn
captures Queen captures and b5 to try
and hold this on then comes Queen a5
check Knight has to block 94 is coming
and white is already under heavy fire
with with pretty it's really nothing to
show for so ever b6 we have Bishop to d6
a very strong idea by Nakamura but but
and not a very good one here Wesley
punishes this move in a quite quite an
enjoyable way he plays nice to e4 and 94
now of course the thread is capturing
the bishop and then recapturing the
extra pawn and the idea behind it is
that if Bishop captures on a fade then
comes Queen to f6 threatening the f2
pawn and also the rook on a1 and you
can't prevent both right so you have to
play something like f3
but now simply rook captures on f8
the threat of queen capture sunny one is
still there you have to capture the
night of course after pawn captures then
you get Queen capture Sunday one and
white is really crushed here white is
down the exchange and his position is
simply terrible
so after this Knight to e4 move we have
Queen to b2 by nakamura now not allowing
Bishop captures because of Queen
captures on g7 but we have a knight
captures and e6 pawn characters and now
Queen to f6 basically forcing Nakamura
to trade Queens here Nakamura could
postpone the trade of Queens by going
Knight to c3
but after considering the position for a
while he does exchange Queens Queen
captures and G captures and now b5 the
be five points protected by the bishop
on f1 and this kind of prevents this
knife from being developed for now so
Bishop character 76 and now a four we
have King to e7 Bishop to d3 and rook to
c8 now and if you can see all of nachus
pieces are pretty much still undeveloped
and he doesn't really have have anything
here with the white pieces so depending
upon like that even if you're a super
Grandmaster will never turn out the way
you imagined Knight to e2 now comes C 5
we have F 3 F 5 rook to a2 and now
Bishop to e6 and here you can see how
how powerful blacks position is already
Wesley is threatening d4 this will open
up and attack to the rock and also
challenge the e3 pawn and here instead
of waiting for for the worst to happen
Nakamura decides to give up a pawn so
rook to c2 given up the e4 pawn
Wesley accepts it Bishop to b4 this
comes with check King to f1 and now rook
captures on a4 we have rook a person
ciated Bishop captures and now Knight to
c3 Knight to c3 with the idea of night
capturing the rook and also capturing
the d5 pawn but Knight the c3 is also
after after playing such such weird
moves you know this was a very eventful
round because
well there were a lot of decisive
results especially with the black pieces
and one of the commentators not Yasir
but your Honka Honka actually said that
it seems that everyone impels themselves
on their own swords and such is the case
with Nakamura here he plays Knight to c3
and this losses immediately so feel free
to pause the video here and figure out
why Knights the sea tree loses
immediately it's not all that difficult
but you know a nice tactic tactics
exercise so uh feel free to do it I will
give it a couple of seconds for those of
you who you know we're able to do it
congratulations you just punished
Nakamura for his terrible blunder and
for the loot we just want to enjoy the
show here better captures on c3 pretty
pretty simple Knight captures and now
rook to a3 simply attacking both pieces
rook to a one nah doesn't win
immediately because white can block this
with nice to be one you're not gonna win
the h1 rook so instead of rook to a3
attacking both of the pieces and after
Knight captures on d5 check King d6
Knight capture some b6 now the bishop
and see it is attacked and now this is
the point Bishop to e6 is the move
White's Bishop is still under attack and
after Bishop to be one which was played
in the game now King to c5 and now you
can see this famous relationship between
a bishop and the knight the bishop is
controlling all of the squares the knife
can jump to the rook is of course
controlling the entire a file so the
knight is completely cut off
Wesley simply plays King to c5 and the
knight has nowhere to go
so simply losing a piece for Nakamura
nice the c8 simply may be dislodging the
bishop for for a for a bit Bishop
captures King to f2 now Bishop to e6 G
for a Nakamura could easily resign but
it's a rapid game you know you never
know F capture some G for Bishop
captures on h7 nice the d7 now rook to
be one may be preparing to push the beef
the b-pawn if Wesley you know allows it
in some crazy way I rocked wait to check
King to g3 and now F capped G captors on
f3
now we have h4 now comes f5 king cap
three and after wisely play Knight to f6
Nakamura resigned the game because there
is simply no counter play to be made
here now whatever you do black always
has a has an excellent response for
example if you push the pawn I try and
promote it then we will simply you can
see that this rope is completely cutting
off king from the second rank and these
two points are completely cutting off
the King from the fourth rank the only
square available to the King is actually
the g3 Square and you can easily fix
that
simply go to Knight to e4 the g3 square
becomes unavailable to the King you're
already threatening rook to f2 checkmate
you have to block this the rook to f1
and now you simply grab a pawn and there
is simply no counter play here for white
so after Knight to f6 and Nakamura
resigned the game and another very nice
victory for Wesley so so this in this
rapid tournament this is a Wesley's
fifth win so he won five games to the
two of the games were drawn and his
rating performance in this tournament so
far is well over three thousand so an
excellent tournament so far by Wesley so
but it's interesting that last year he
was also in the lead at the one Magnus
caught someone but then at the end of
the tournament he was he was not even in
the top three but it's still very early
in the tournament they're still after
today's rapid there are still two more
blitz days so you know anything can
happen regarding the final standings I'm
gonna I'm probably gonna cover one more
game from from day three of the rap
tournament and we're gonna check out the
standings after that so yeah I do hope
you enjoyed this game Korra Nakamura
definitely didn't and best of luck to
everyone in the photo challenge I would
like to thank Steven Steven Gerrard's
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here both of them will be from
the from this very nice rapid tournament
i thankful for watching and i will see
you soon with hopefully another nice
game